Today we will examine the duress defense.
If someone holds a gun to your head and demands that you signed a contract.
That contract,
as you might suspect becomes voidable at your option.
Threats of your money or your life do not produce valid evidence of welfare
enhancing trade,
but not all forms of duress are of this kind of physical threat.
What if someone threatens to breach a contract unless you agree to modify its
terms?
Economic Duress can also make a contract.
Voidable we will explore the concept of economic duress in Austin versus Laurel
decided by the Court of Appeals of New York in 1971
the defendant and buyer Laurel is a frequent government contractor.
Laurel contracted with the U S Navy to provide radar sets in order to have the
necessary parts to make these radar sets.
Laurel had to subcontract with the plaintiff and Seller Austin Instrument.
Laurel was awarded a second navy contract and inform to Austin that Austin would
be oh awarded only those subcontracts for which it was the lowest bidder.
Austin unhappy with this change decided to play hardball.
Austin threatened to cease delivery under its first to sub contract unless the
defendant agreed to a substantial increase in the contract price.
Lorell contacted 10 alternative precision gear manufacturers,
but couldn't find any that could provide the parts in time.
Faced with the prospect of being unable to meet the government's deadline,
Laurel knuckled under and agreed to Austin's demands and awarded the second sub
contract to Austin at the higher cost.
After the parts were delivered,
Lorell refuse to pay the full price.
Boston brought suit to recover 17,750 bucks,
allegedly due on the second sub contract.
Laurel itself brought suit,
claiming recovery of the price increase on the first subcontract.
The two actions were consolidated.
The trial judge found for Austin in the first complaint and dismissed the second
the appellate division affirmed and the instant court affirmed as to the first
action and reversed as to the second.
So what were the prevailing military exigencies mentioned in the opinion?
Well,
the answer is the Vietnam War.
This is relevant because our soldiers lies.
We're potentially at stake.
If Lorell couldn't produce the radar sets,
then American soldiers,
uh,
might be killed.
This important political background may have the court's decision and as a more
general matter,
it's useful to keep track of whether there was an economic or military crisis
happening when a court is deciding the case.
The main issue in this case is whether our contractual modification made under
economic duress is voidable.
The court found that yes,
economic duress can avoid a contract.
Economic Duress exists when three conditions are met.
One,
one party threatens to breach a contract to the threatened party,
cannot cover their obligation with another source.
And three,
the ordinary remedy for breach of contract is inadequate.
The court found that all three of these conditions were met in his dissent.
Judge Bergon argued that a finding of economic duress relies on the
determination of fact and that the trial court found no duress
more generally,
the court attempted to define the legal standard for economic duress.
It stated that quote,
a contract is voidable on the grounds of dress.
When it does establish that the party making the claim was forced to agree to it
by means of a wrongful threat precluding the exercise of his freewill unquote.
Let's break down the key terms of this legal standard.
The wrongful threat in this case was the threat to breach the contract.
Why was failure deliver a wrongful threat?
Well,
because there was a prior contract and a preexisting duty to provide radar
headsets.
This is different from the ski or hypothetical that we've discussed in past
lectures.
Were a rescuer demands $1 million to take a skier with a broken leg down a
mountain because the rescue or has no,
because in this case,
the rescuer has no preexisting duty to take the skier down the mountain.
Uh,
here,
Austin had a preexisting duty to deliver the parts under this first contract.
One of the key sources of duress is the failure of contractual damages.
If expectation damages fully compensated the primacy for a breach of contract,
there would not be anything,
uh,
threatening about a breach.
The promise he could say,
go ahead and reach.
I won't even notice if you breach because I'll be made whole,
uh,
and put in such a good position that I,
as if the breach had not occurred.
But legal damages often do not fully compensate.
Promises are not awarded their attorney's fees and more importantly,
a promise or is sometimes have shallow pockets and cannot pay the damages that
are awarded.
The doctrine therefore is a substitute for the failure of,
of damages,
uh,
in contractual actions.
It's noteworthy that this court disposed of the case in terms of the dress
element without so much as a mention of the preexisting duty a doctrine or UCC
section two,
two Oh nine,
we call that two two oh nine one deals with modifications to contracts and
states that a modification to an existing contract does not need consideration.
Uh,
but it does need a still be in good faith.
Austin's attempt at modifying the contract in this case was in bad faith.
Can it ever be unlawful to threaten what one has a legal right to do?
While on first glance it might appear that it's always lawful to threaten what
one has a legal right to do,
but this is actually not the case.
A common,
a counter example is a threat of criminal prosecution as an improper means of
inducing the recipient to a contract which constitutes a misuse for personal
gain of the power given for other legitimate ends.
The person making the threat is legally allowed to call the authorities and
report a criminal violation,
but the threat itself is still unlawful in the eyes of contract law.
Even a threat of civil process may under exceptional circumstances be abusive.
Quote,
if the threat is shown to have been made in bad faith,
for instance,
it's wrongful for a husband to threatened to inform the IRS of his wife's tax
innovation if she does not sign a settlement agreement.
Duress,
as such is seldom recognized as an independent tort.
The victim does not usually maintain an act and action for damages in the usual
case,
duress is pleaded as a defense or as a basis for avoiding a transaction and
securing restitutional relief.
Moreover,
the issues seldom arises in connection with initial contract formation.
Most often,
there is an attempt to bar enforcement of a contract modification or a
settlement agreement.
Uh,
Laurel was an example of trying to stop the enforcement of a modification.
There are two main types of dress discussed in the second restatement.
The first is a physical duress.
Normally dress by physical compulsion prevents formation of a contract,
whereas duressed by other threats makes it contract.
Voidable restatement.
Second Section one 75 discusses how nonphysical duress can render a contract.
Voidable quote,
if a party's manifestation of the scent is induced by an improper threat by the
other party,
that leaves the victim.
No reasonable alternative.
The contract is voidable by the victim.
Another related but separate concept is undue influence.
The rule for duress was developed by courts of law.
While the rule of undue influence is similar to that of duress,
it was developed by courts of equity.
Undue influence is characterized by unfair persuasion that may fall short of
constituting actual duress.
The key is usually high pressure that approaches the boundaries of coercion,
limited to situations where there is a relationship of trust or confidence such
as a parent and child,
a husband and wife or attorney and client,
but it also can include dysfunctional relationships of domination.
Under undue influence has also been found in where a confidential relationship,
uh,
in the usual sense does not exist.
In one case,
a school teacher was arrested on criminal charges of homosexuality,
homosexual activity and after conferring with school officials submitted a
letter of resignation.
The very next day,
a month later,
the criminal charges were dismissed and the teacher suit for rescission of the
resignation and other appropriate relief.
The court found that undue influence,
quote over persuasion unquote existed because of several factors,
including discussing the resignation at an unusual and inappropriate time,
uh,
extreme emphasis on untoward consequences of delay and stating that there is no
time to consult financial advisors or attorneys.
In summary,
economic duress can render a contract voidable the threat to breach a contract
can constitute economic duress if the innocent party cannot cover its
obligations from another source and ordinary contract damages are inadequate.
Physical duress usually prevents the formation of the contract,
whereas nonphysical wrongful threats render a contract voidable.
Finally,
many courts also recognize the defense of undue influence,
high pressure exerted in relationships of trust or confidence,
uh,
or domination,
which can also render a contract voidable.